[Music]
hi my name is Nicholas Christakis and
I'm a physician and a social scientist
and the discipline I'm going to be
speaking to you about today is sociology
sociology is the field in which you
study human behavior and human
experience and how it relates to the
fact that individuals are embedded
within larger groups and collections of
individuals when you see an individual
as a member of a group or of a
collectivity you get a completely
different perspective on that person and
on the group's of which they're a member
in sociology we explore a fundamental
tension on the one hand you yourself
have your own identity and your own
agency and your own ability to make
choices that affect your life but on the
other hand there is a collective
responsibility for your life as well
super individual factors like where you
live or where you are located in these
vast face-to-face networks that we human
beings assemble or what kinds of formal
institutions are near you like
governments or hospitals for example can
have as much to do with what happens to
you in your life as the own as your own
decisions and your own actions this is
the difference between structure and
agency between collective constraints
and opportunities that constrain and
permit you to do certain kinds of things
in your life on the one hand and your
own individual choices and actions that
permit you to do other sorts of things
on the other hand that's the first big
idea that I'd like to communicate today
a second key idea in sociology is that
collective phenomena are not mere
aggregations of individual phenomena
there's something special something
weird almost about groups of individuals
about collectivities something weird
that you cannot see if you just study
individuals but that you must study
whole groups of people in order to
really understand
so how did I become interested in these
crazy ideas actually I started my career
as a physician and I went to medical
school and at the time I wanted to be a
reconstructive surgeon and I wanted to
operate on people who had craniofacial
abnormalities or people whose
extremities had been cut off and
reattached these extremities and I used
to cut class my first year of medical
school and go operate with some of the
surgeons at the Children's Hospital in
Boston and I did this for quite a while
and eventually as we would operate on
these kids they were primarily kids one
after another day after day I came to
the realization that the kind of
healthcare that I wanted to practice was
not the kind that took care of people
one at a time but rather the kind that
tried to take care of whole populations
of people I mean I wanted to understand
why do groups of people become sick not
just why do individuals become sick and
how can we make groups become well not
just individuals become well one at a
time and part of this was prompted by my
realization that I was running around
putting my fingers in the dike one hole
after another was springing water and we
were running around all of us trying to
plug these holes and I was interested in
how can we make a better dike how can we
make a situation in which fewer people
become sick to begin with in which we
spring fewer holes to begin with in the
dike as it were and in fact I began to
ask what I came eventually to see as
sociological questions about the origins
of illness and disease and suffering and
death in our society and I wanted to
understand how we could have a
sociological response a collective
response to these sorts of problems and
in fact this dovetails to some extent
with an interest in public health which
can be constructed with a kind of
interest in clinical medicine which
takes care of patients one at a time
[Applause]
so sociological ideas find widespread
application in public policy and in
public health
anytime you design an intervention where
you intend to affect large groups of
people instead of individuals you're
conducting a sociological intervention
so for example when we think about
public policies that affect our public
spaces how we design our cities for
example or we think about mass media
campaigns to get people to change their
sexual practices for example those are
examples of sociological interventions
interventions which don't just seek to
take into account individual desires but
their interventions which seek to take
into account the whole structure around
the individual the structure in which
the individual is embedded because by
changing the structure you can also
change the individual so let's start by
taking a look at a personal Testament a
very seemingly individualistic statement
that a human being is making about their
own life about what would seem to be a
quintessentially private individualistic
decision namely whether to take your own
life and to commit suicide this is
Charlotte Perkins Gilman suicide note
she was 75 years old when she took her
life the time is approaching when we
shall consider it abhorrence to our
civilization to allow a human being to
die in prolonged agony which we should
mercifully end in any other creature
believing this choice to be of social
service in promoting wiser views on this
question I have preferred chloroform to
cancer despite the fact that this woman
is taking her life and despite the fact
that she's writing a suicide note
notice that the note contains or alludes
to a kind of connections to others even
as she was ending her own life she
bemoans the fact that society is not
sensitive to her pain and even while
dying she's trying to make a
contribution to society she's trying to
be connected to other individuals here's
another note dear God please have mercy
on my soul please forgive me I can't
stand the pain anymore and that note was
written by a 76 year old grandmother
who isolated by depression and
disability crawled into her basement
freezer to kill herself by the cold and
you might ask what kind of a social
system permits this to happen permits
one of its members to be so alone to
feel so isolated that this is the choice
that they would make and in fact you
might ask was this suicide truly an
individual act was it really purely an
individual choice another one ron burst
jumped off the Golden Gate Bridge and in
his will he donated ten thousand dollars
to AIDS research
this is his note to the San Francisco
Police Department or equivalent
jurisdiction this is to state that I Ron
our bursts did take my own life due to
the fact that I have the disease AIDS
and it is progressed both rapidly and to
the point where number one I constantly
feel ill and have almost no energy and
number two I very soon expect to become
a burden to my friends and family and I
do not want to put any of them through
such an ordeal I sincerely regret any
inconvenience that this may have caused
anyone involved I honestly believe that
a fast end such as this while one is
still able yet ill enough to justify it
is is easier on my close friends who
have been so unbelievably supportive
emotionally for me
and my family who have been no less so
than to drag this out I did not give up
so again in mr. Bursch note noticed the
social concern his death is not an
individual act at all first of all it
was public he jumped off the Golden Gate
Bridge people saw him second it was
guided by a concern for others he's
worried about his friends and family and
third it's infused with the social ties
that connect him to his family and his
friends now there's another way that
suicide is social as well it's not just
the connection the individual has to
others it's the responsibility that
others have to the individual it's about
how social and structural factors
constrain or permit individual acts even
like suicide for example this is an
image of the Golden Gate Bridge from
which Ron bursts jumped and this bridge
is unusual in its design
because the sidewalk as you can see is
directly next to the edge he walked
along the sidewalk and then just jumped
over that railing stood there and jumped
right over this is a picture of Kevin
Hines who almost met the same fate as
mr. burst in September of 2000 at the
age of 19 suffering from depression he
went to the Golden Gate Bridge and he
stood there for 40 minutes crying no one
approached him to ask what was wrong and
then eventually a tourist came up and
asked him if he could take her
photograph Hines interpreted this as a
clear sign that no one cared he took the
picture and then when she walked away he
turned around and he jumped right over
the railing but instantly he says he
realized that he had made a mistake he
changed his mind oh he thought I
don't want to die what am I going to do
he later recalled in midair he came up
with a plan to save his life as he
described as follows
it was simply this a god save me be
throw your head back and see hit feet
first it takes four seconds to drop the
220 feet from the height of the Golden
Gate Bridge to the water and you
eventually reach a speed of 75 miles per
hour and among the over 1,200 people who
have jumped off the bridge since 1937
only 26 are believed to have survived
and interestingly a large percentage of
those who attempt the jump when they're
interviewed afterwards say that they
regretted the decision as soon as they
jumped for example another jumper Ken
Baldwin was 28 and also severely
depressed in August of 1985 when he
jumped and he later said the following
thing I still see my hands coming off
the railing I instantly realized that
everything in my life that I thought was
unfixable was totally fixable except for
having just jumped even allowing for the
fact that we cannot know what all the
successful suicides would have said had
we been able to interview them these
kinds of reports by people who jumped
and survived begged the question of how
to prevent these kinds of supposedly
purely individual acts
what would happen to these people if
somehow society could have prevented
them from jumping if there somehow had
been a structure in place which had
constrained the agency of these
individuals one landmark study conducted
in 1978 of 515 people who were removed
from the Golden Gate Bridge before they
had jumped and followed them for an
average of about 26 years afterwards
found that 94% were still alive or had
died of natural causes many years later
so suicidal behavior is acute and crisis
driven and if the individual is
prevented from acting on their suicidal
impulses by those around him it might
not be repeated there are quite a number
of remarkable things about such stories
no doubt these individuals and their
illnesses are central actors in the
experience of the individual but I want
to highlight two other observations one
is the role of the perceived
indifference expressed by the person
that Kevin encountered because this
highlights an important theme or an
important idea in sociology namely the
idea that we are all connected to each
other the role of connection in our
experience of the world and the role of
our embeddedness in others is in fact a
key consideration or a key point that
sociologists are interested in
[Music]
the other important thing to realize
from these stories is the importance of
extra individual factors that help
determine individual outcomes as I
alluded to the role of structure versus
the role of agency now the Golden Gate
Bridge has a footpath adjacent to the
railing unlike most bridges and people
still regularly kill themselves from it
and if you look at the Golden Gate
Bridge you can see some ideas about how
we might constrain individual agency how
we might as a society respond to prevent
people from jumping for example suicide
barriers such as this one at other sites
have drastically reduced and often even
eliminated suicides such as it the
Eiffel Tower the Empire State Building
or the Sydney Harbour Bridge but a
barrier has not been put at the Golden
Gate Bridge for reasons that many myself
included find a bit bit silly namely
that it would somehow ruin the
aesthetics of the bridge but here's an
artist's rendering of one possible
solution and it doesn't look so bad this
argument it turns out has been around
for years but finally in February of
2010 the Golden Gate Bridge board after
many years of lobbying agreed to put
some suicide Nets under the bridge to
catch jumpers but they did not agree to
assign the use of any toll revenue for
this purpose so still there's nothing
there to prevent suicide so this is a
particularly specific and dramatic
illustration of the interplay between
structure and agency between policy
decisions made at the collective level
and the ability of an individual even to
stay alive moreover this is a
particularly powerful illustration not
only of the issue of structure versus
agency but also of more complicated
ideas namely the issue of group level
phenomena or of emergence which is the
second big idea I'd like to talk to you
about today
[Applause]
now suicide has been used as an example
to illustrate this idea ever since 1897
by a very famous sociologist by the name
of Emile Durkheim
who wrote about this topic he was
looking at suicide rates in different
religious groups in different periods in
France and he found that these rates are
constant across time and vary across
religious groups even though the
individuals members of those groups in
those particular times change
dramatically
so the Protestants in 1800 of France are
completely different than the human
beings who are the Protestants in 1850
France and yet the suicide rate let's
say is the same hence this constancy of
rates and this variation across
societies is indicative of something
else going on beyond individual choice
or individual biology it's as if society
determines this seemingly purely
individual act this seemingly purely
individual choice and Durkheim had a
number of arguments including the
following
he wrote the individual is dominated by
a moral reality greater than himself
namely collective reality so you see
groups can have properties of their own
and the individuals within them are
affected by those properties
[Music]
one way to understand these ideas of
structure and agency and of emergence
and of the relevance of collections of
individuals and how they can affect the
individuals within those collections is
to think about social networks
sociologists have been studying social
networks
beginning with the pioneering work of
Georg Simmel in the 1890s and they've
been doing this studying networks for
well over a hundred years and social
networks are one particular kind of
super individual factor that can affect
individual choices that can shape your
destiny and shape what happens to you in
your life now by social networks I don't
mean facebook or myspace or the kinds of
recent networks that many of you might
be thinking about I actually mean the
kind of face-to-face networks that human
beings have been making for tens of
thousands of years in fact ever since we
lived on the African savannah now each
of us forms or inherits certain kinds of
connections to friends to co-workers to
our relatives to our neighbors and each
of those individuals in turn also has
friends and co-workers and relatives and
neighbors and as a result of this we
form this incredibly ornate almost
baroque structure known as social
networks and we proceed to live out our
lives and bedded within these networks
now what's the difference between a
group and a network here's a group and a
group you know maybe of a hundred people
but a network in addition to the hundred
people also has ties the ties that
connect the people to each other and it
has specific ties at that and there are
two kinds of networks artificial
networks and natural networks here's an
example of one of the simplest type of
artificial networks you can imagine a
bucket brigade a bucket brigade is an
arrangement in which you line people up
and you have a bucket that moves from
one end to the other people pass the
bucket along and this can be done either
to transport water for example to put
out a fire this is an old-fashioned
technology that people used or it can
also be used to transport debris if you
want to transport to agree a great
distance instead of having people
running haphazardly transporting buckets
one at a time you can have a series of
buckets that are run to the front
and the full buckets are moved to the
rear of the line it's a simple linear
network it has a hundred people to which
we've added 99 ties everyone is
connected to the guy on the right and to
the guy on the left and assembling the
people in this fashion gives this group
of people properties it didn't have
before like the ability to efficiently
transport debris or the ability to put
out a fire
if these people weren't assembled in the
network in this fashion this linear
network they couldn't do it as well as
they otherwise might or you could take
the same hundred people and the same
number of ties and organize them in the
form of a telephone tree this was an
old-fashioned technology to efficiently
transmit information before we had the
internet so the person in the middle
indicated by the arrow he would have a
list of two people that he was supposed
to call let's say to notify everyone
about the closure of a school because of
a snow day or something he would call
two people each of those people would
call two people and the information
about the school closure would rapidly
and efficiently and accurately be
transmitted throughout this group or we
could take the same number of people a
hundred people but now a different
number of ties and assemble them into a
completely different organization for
example into military companies here we
have a hundred men and women composed
into ten squads of ten people and within
each squad everyone knows each other
very well there's a dense
interconnection of ties in this kind of
organization this kind of structural
organization is able to elicit from
these individuals something that wasn't
present there before namely a
willingness to die for each other so
this structural form of organizing
people is able to call forth from the
individual people or foster the
emergence of new properties that weren't
necessarily there before
[Music]
but natural social networks look nothing
like the artificial networks we just saw
they look more like this network here's
a slide in fact of such a natural
network illustrating one of our own
studies and this image was one that we
made in order to help understand the
role of social networks in the obesity
epidemic beginning a few years ago maybe
10 or 20 years ago it had become
fashionable to speak about the obesity
epidemic and it was clear that obesity
was epidemic in one meaning of the word
meaning that there's more of it than
there was before for example just in the
last 10 years the prevalence of obesity
has gone from about 20% to about 30% and
fully 2/3 of Americans are now
overweight or obese so something is
going on that has given rise to an
increasing amount of obesity and there
are a number of structural factors that
have been suggested as causing the
obesity epidemic because we don't really
believe that there's something
biological going on here even though the
individual's biology can explain
variation between people and how big
they are our biology hasn't changed that
much over the last 30 years so something
social something else must be going on
to help explain why obesity has been
rising so much and people have offered a
number of structural explanations
maybe there's a declining real price of
food food is cheaper than it used to be
so by basic economics you're going to
buy more of it
maybe it's the marketing of food the way
food is marketed to us or the fat
composition of food or there been other
sorts of changes that affect how many
calories we use up every day in the
course of our lives we have more
sedentary lifestyles there's been a
change in occupations we have a more
service-oriented economy than a labor
oriented economy there's a changing pace
of life in our society the design of our
cities urban design and suburban design
people don't move around as much anymore
and people had offered all of these
kinds of explanations for the obesity
epidemic but we wondered whether we
could add an explanation whether we
could understand obesity as being truly
epidemic as if something were spreading
from person to person it wasn't just a
metaphoric epidemic it was a literal
epidemic could we find evidence for a
kind of social contagion whereby weight
gain in one person could affect weight
gain in other people to whom they work
Connect
and in fact we began to think about
obesity in a sociological way could we
think about obesity and the epidemic of
obesity as being somehow related to the
suicide example I was discussing earlier
where something collective seems to be
determining individual's likelihood of
killing themselves could something
collective be contributing to
individuals changing their body size so
to the extent that obesity is a product
of personal choices and voluntary
behaviors the fact that people are
embedded in social networks and are
influenced by the appearance and
behaviors of those around them led us to
suppose that it might be possible to
find evidence of the spread of obesity
within social networks so we needed a
special kind of data to do this and this
image shows 2,200 people drawn from the
very famous Framingham Heart Study in
the year 2000 every dot is a person and
every line between them represents a
relationship between the two people
bigger dots are bigger people and in
addition we color the dots yellow if
people are properly obese and if you
look at this image you can see
clustering of obese and non-obese
individuals within the image it's still
a very complicated image but if you
study it mathematically you can find
evidence of these clusters clusters of
yellow and red dots so that people's
body size seems to be related to the
body size of other people to whom they
are connected and we were able to
analyze these data and discern evidence
for the clustering and interpersonal
influence such that if people around you
gained or lost weight it affected you as
well and it seemed to spread from person
to person and from person to person in
person and even from person to person to
person to person
so that weight gain seemed to and weight
loss seemed to spread within the network
and one uses various kinds of
statistical methods to analyze such data
ranging from all kinds of statistical
models to social network analysis to
actual experiments that one can do now
in the process of studying the obesity
epidemic we did something else as well
because we also made movies about how
social networks change across time and
our initial motivation was to see if we
could literally visualize the spread of
obesity from person to person to person
to person
within the network many of you may have
done an experiment in high school in
which you took a water table and you
dropped a pebble on the water and then
you had these waves that emerge from
where the pebble hit the water and these
waves would hit the perimeter of the
table and bounce back and if you did it
just right you would get a standing wave
on the surface of the water and if you
didn't do that experiment you probably
had another experience as a kid which
was sloshing around in your bathtub and
you probably remember that if you
sloshed just right in your bathtub you
can get your body into sink with a wave
and get a big wave that'll come out of
the bathtub and splash onto the floor
and make a big mess and that's a kind of
a standing wave as well and what we
thought we'd be able to do would be to
see waves of obesity within the social
network because you can imagine networks
as a kind of social topological surface
a kind of hyper dimensional surface and
that it might be possible to see waves
within this network so that is I gained
weight it makes my friends gain weight
and as my friends gain weight it makes
their friends gain weight and though and
you literally could get a wave within
the surface so this little video
animation about to show you was both the
most exciting and the most depressing
moment of my scientific career ok so
again every dot is a person every line
between them is a relationship again we
make the dot size proportional to
people's body mass index so bigger dots
are bigger people and we color the dots
yellow if they're properly obese and on
this image we only show two kinds of
relationships the gray lines indicate
spousal connections and the purple lines
indicate friendship connections so two
people connected by line it's not
because they share genes in common these
are purely volitional social
relationships and so in a minute we're
going to take put this network into
motion we're going to take daily cuts
through the network for 32 years every
single day evaluating the structure and
status of the network and what you're
going to see across time is you're going
to see people be born and die images
nodes are going to appear and disappear
you're going to see a relationships form
and break you're going to see marriages
and divorces friending and defriending
x' the real old-fashioned kind of D
friending not the Facebook kind of D
friending and you're going to see people
people get bigger and smaller as people
gain and lose weight mostly you're going
to see the dots getting bigger and
you're going to see a sea of yellow
because this period of time from 1971 to
2003 in
cludes the period of the obesity
epidemic and when you look at this image
I want you to think about as we were
thinking about could we see a wave
evidence of spread in the image okay so
now you've seen the network evolve
people are marrying and divorcing each
other friending and defriending each
other you're going to see people gain
weight and lose weight mostly they're
going to gain weight now you're going to
see the growth of the epidemic you're
going to see mostly a sea of yellow at
this point in time as the epidemic is
really kicking off and we're approaching
the end of the of the animation now in
just a moment and by the end you can see
that there are clusters of obese and
non-obese yellow and green sectors
within the network but when you look at
this the question is did you see this
wave or not and we didn't see it like I
said this was both the most exciting and
the most depressing moments of our
scientific careers because we were
convinced that if we went to the trouble
to collect these data and make this type
of an image after five and a half years
of effort we'd be able to see this wave
but when we looked at this we didn't see
it and it took us a whole day to figure
out why and the reason is that obesity
is not a eunice centric epidemic it
doesn't have a point source
it's a multi centric epidemic it has
many sources and the proper analogy is
not a single pebble being dropped on the
surface of a pond but a whole handful of
rocks being thrown on the surface every
rock falling plunk plunk plunk makes
these little concentric waves but the
waves interfere with each other
and you get this choppy surface this
chop on this socio topological surface
this hyper dimensional object that is a
social network so other kinds of
statistical and mathematical tools were
required to discover or uncover the
extent to which there is a wave and
using these tools we were eventually
able to show this type of influence from
person to person within the network but
the interesting thing as we made this
image was that it totally shifted my
perspective on what was happening here
because I came to see the world
differently this network when you look
at it it moves things flow within it it
changes and evolves
it's resilient to injury it has a memory
it has a kind of a coherence and an
indoor
across time I came to see social
networks as living things as a kind of
human super organism they have a life of
their own of which we are all apart and
you can think of human beings in this
way as having these kinds of properties
these emergent properties because we
partake of this bigger hole because
we're a part of this other living thing
you can think of us as being constituent
parts of it and our membership in this
bigger thing affects us just like the
point Durkheim was making earlier about
the suicide rates in France in the
nineteenth century
so now what might be some possible
mechanisms or explanations of the spread
of obesity so here we might think of the
altar that's the other person and the
ego that's you so one possibility is
that the alters appearance or behavior
could change the egos appearance or
behavior so for example your friends say
let's go have muffins and beer
it's a terrible combination but your
friends suggested it so you copy your
friends behavior and you gain weight as
a result of the muffin and beer diet
that you've assumed a second possibility
is that the alters appearance or
behavior changes your expectations or
perceptions of norms here what spreads
from person to person is not a behavior
but rather an idea and when we analyze
our data we found evidence for both
sorts of phenomena we found some
suggestive evidence that as your as the
people around you change their body size
it resets your expectations about what
an acceptable body size is and so you go
on to gain weight or lose weight
accordingly as well
now many social sciences take people's
tastes and desires as a given and they
try to figure out why people do what
they do given that they have particular
tastes or desires how do they maximize
their utility but one of the distinctive
ideas of sociology is that it seeks to
understand where do these tastes and
desires come from in the first place why
do you want what you want why do you
desire what you desire and in part it
turns out that our desires and our wants
are determined by the collective are
determined by the groups of which we are
members and longshoremen and social
critic Eric Hoffer once opined when
people are free to do as they please
they usually imitate
each other our choices and experiences
depend on what others around us are
doing and feeling from obesity to
smoking to voting or even to our
emotions and in a sense this means that
we have less free will than we think we
might have now one can also ask other
deeper questions like why do social
networks look the way that they do they
always kind of look like the image I
showed you earlier of the obesity
Network but they never look like a
regular lattice why don't we live our
lives in this kind of a structure why
don't we make networks that look like
this well the striking patterns of human
social networks their ubiquity and their
apparent purpose beg the question of
whether we have evolved to have them and
to have particular kinds of networks in
the first place
and so now the questions become why do
we form social networks in the first
place and why do they have the structure
that they do and understand this we need
to dissect network structure a little
bit first so first of all notice that in
this network every position is the same
as every other position
everyone has eight friends every one of
their friends in turn has eight friends
and if you took this surface and you
wrapped it around the surface of a
doughnut of a torus there would no be
there would be nobody that was any more
towards the edge or towards the middle
of the network
everyone would be equidistant from the
edge
[Applause]
[Music]
natural social networks are very
different so for example if you look at
this network you can see that different
individuals have different kinds of
locations within the network consider
for example individuals B and D so B has
four connections and D has six
connections and if you talk to those
individuals they would know this about
themselves I've got four friends I've
got six friends I've got no friends I've
got ten friends people know this about
themselves and that's obvious but there
are other aspects of our network that
are less obvious for example compare
contrast nodes a and B they're different
they both have four friends but A's
friends are by large friends with each
other and B's friends are not friends
with each other this is known as
transitivity the friend of a friend of
a's is back again a friend of a's but
the friend of a friend of Bees is not a
friend of B's it reaches further within
the network and if you look at C and D
you can see that they're different they
both have six friends but there's
something different about see compared
to D and I can cultivate this intuition
in you by asking you who would you
rather be if a deadly germ was spreading
through the network
you'd rather be D you should have the
intuition that it's better to be on the
edge of the network because that person
would be less likely to get what's
spreading and if they get it are more
likely to get it later in the course of
the epidemic now let me ask you who
would you rather be if a juicy piece of
gossip we're spreading through the
network
now you'd rather be C be in the middle
of the network and get it
this can be formalized mathematically
the difference between these individuals
and it's known as I said as their
centrality and this bird's-eye view of
the network makes these sorts of
differences apparent and it turns out
that where you're located within the
network whether you are a B C or D or
types of individuals like that depends
in part on your genes again depending on
the circumstances faced different
positions are different so people often
say well what's the best location in the
network the answer is it depends if a
germ is spreading through the network
it's better to be in one place if
information about where to find a job is
spreading through the network it's
better to be in another place
so you can think of networks as a kind
of vast fabric of humanity and we all
occupy particular spots
within the network
there's another way that social networks
affect us it's not just what's happening
to the people around us that might
ripple through the network and affect us
it's the actual structure of the network
itself now think about these two objects
they're both made of carbon but if you
look at the structure of the objects the
graphite on the left is made of carbon
atoms assembled and connected one way
and the diamond on the right is made of
carbon atoms assembled and connected
another way so you connect the carbon
atoms one way and you get graphite which
is soft and dark and you connect the
carbon atoms another way you get Diamond
which is hard and clear and there are
two key intellectual ideas from this
observation first these properties of
softness and darkness and hardness and
clearness do not in here in the carbon
atoms there are not properties of the
carbon atoms their properties of the
collection of carbon atoms second which
properties you get depends on how you
connect the carbon atoms to each other
and similarly the pattern of our
connections with each other affects the
properties of groups
it's the ties between people that make
the whole greater than the sum of its
parts
new properties emerge because of the
connections between people because of
the ties between people and not
necessarily because of the people
themselves and in fact our experience of
the world depends in part on the actual
structure of the social network ties
around us and this is like the
artificial networks we saw at the
beginning of the bucket brigade and the
telephone tree you take human beings and
you assemble them one way you get one
set of properties you assemble them
another way you get a different set of
properties just like the carbon example
so here's a more specific human example
of how social network structure can
affect the Constituent individuals this
is some work done by Brian you'd see at
a sociologist at Northwestern University
he became very interested in Broadway
musicals and why some Broadway musicals
are big success and other Broadway
musicals are a total disaster and what
he did is he put together a sample of
three over 300 Broadway musical
production companies and he looked at
the structure of the of the production
company the network structure and
assessed how was associated with the
financial success and the critical
acclaim of the Broadway shows that those
companies put on so here you see cartoon
images of how the networks might be
assembled you see that there's a central
individual connected to five other
people and amongst those people there
can be five times four divided by two
ten possible connections and in the
cartoon you see there none of those
connections zero of ten of the ties are
present and we would say that there's
zero percent density in this network or
you might see that the all ten of the
ties are present so you have 10 out of
10 100 percent density and densities
sort of like transitivity that we were
talking about earlier or four of the ten
ties are present so you have 40 percent
density and what hootsie did was is he
plotted on the x-axis the density of the
Broadway musical production company and
on the y-axis how successful the
Broadway musical was how much money did
it make and how many favorable reviews
did it get and as you see by the
parabolic shape on the Left if you have
a network in which nobody knew each
other from before the show was a flop
and at the other extreme if you see that
everybody knew each other from before
the show was a flop but in the middle if
some of the people knew each other from
before and some of the people didn't
know each other from before the show was
a big success so it seems to matter here
is it's not just the individuals putting
on the show it's the structure of the
network that affects the likely success
of the show and you see has gone on to
show that there's similar work or
similar findings with respect to
scientific collaborations and other
sorts of groups that people can assemble
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now it turns out we're not the only
species that assemble assembles
ourselves into networks and gives rise
to other sorts of special properties and
so to push this point home this point
about emergence this idea that
collectivities can have properties that
are not present in the individuals
themselves let's consider a further
example this is a slime mold it's a
primitive amoeboid fungus and all this
fungus does is the just wood so this
thing lives on the forest floor
and if you've ever lifted up like a pile
of leaves in the fall and they're wet
and soggy and you've seen those little
white tubes under that's what this thing
is doing the little fungus forms
connections to other nearby fungus as
they fuse and they make these long tubes
and they digest wood and they distribute
the waste from their digestion through
these tubes um but it turns out
individuals of this species in
connecting to each other form a kind of
super organism with unexpected
properties for example they can solve
mazes so if you take a maze and you put
it on a kind of agar plate and you put
food at two different spots the entrance
and the exit to the maze and buy food
here I mean like something like wood or
like an oat flake if you put oat flakes
at the entrance or the exit of the maze
this simple organism will change its
shape and connect the two sources of
food by finding the minimum path length
solution between the two points if parts
of the organism are spread out on the
gel they will reassemble to form a kind
of single super organism and so they
events a kind of maze solving property a
kind of primitive intelligence that's
not present in the individual organisms
themselves and this work was done by a
Japanese mycologist by the name of Toshi
naka gachi it's the fungi working
collectively that give rise to this this
property this may solving ability that
emerges from their interactions in fact
you can use this kind of a maze solving
ability or this ability to find the
optimal paths to uh to do other sorts of
things like here we show an image on the
left is the rail network designed by
human beings in England and on the right
is some work done by my colleague mark
Fricker
Oxford University he took the map of
England and he put little oat flakes at
every city and he plated the amoeboid
fungus and the amoeboid fungus gave rise
to a path connecting or set of paths
connecting the the old flakes that
actually imitated and in many ways was
better than the rail wet Network the
human beings had designed over two
hundred years so if you look at these
two things side by side you see that the
fungus is able to design a railway
system for England in fact a better
system than the one that they have still
what's the point of a connected life how
does it help us as an individual or as a
species it turns out that social
networks are a resource that we can all
use they're a kind of social capital now
most people when they think about
capital think about money but really
capital is any stock of resources that
can be put to productive use to further
key ideas about capital are that in
order to create capital you have to
invest skill and effort you have to know
something and do something in order to
acquire capital and second and more
subtle you have to work upon the world
and transmute it you have to change the
world you have to introduce changes in a
substance that makes it more productive
than it was before
that makes it capable of yielding a
higher rate of return than it was able
to do before
so for example think about this you can
have a forest you can invest skill and
effort you can clear the forest and you
can make a farm and this farm is a stock
of capital it's more productive at least
in terms of fruits and vegetables and
grains then the forest was and by
investing skill and effort and working
upon the land and changing the land you
have created a reservoir of wealth
something that's capable of being used
in a fashion that wasn't possible before
so land and especially improved land is
a form of capital or think about this
idea you can take this tree you can
invest skill and effort and you can
transmute the substance of the tree and
mill it into lumber and the lumber is
more valuable than the tree you can
invest still more skill and effort and
convert the lumber into a violin which
is more valuable than
the tree because it reflects this
additional investment of skill and
effort and because in having changed the
wood even more you're now capable of
doing things with a violin you couldn't
do with a lumber like make music so
capital is a change that allows a
substance to act in new ways and this is
part of what makes it a store of wealth
and a source of productive power now key
innovation in thinking among social
scientists took place in the 1960s
spearheaded primarily by economist Gary
Becker to begin to think about human
beings as a form of human capital and
the chief example of this is education
if we endow someone with skills and
knowledge we have changed them and they
have become more productive so if you
look at this sort of dissolute graduate
student of mine you can invest skill and
effort you can clean him up so that he's
no longer a drunkard and now he's
capable of doing things he wasn't
capable of doing before or you can
invest still more skill and effort and
give him an education and now he's even
more able to do things he wasn't able to
do before so you have changed the
substance of his mind
you have reworked the real world you
have taught him things you have changed
his brain and made him more productive
and more capable of doing things that he
wasn't previously able to do
[Music]
now just like physical capital is
created by a change in the material
world and human capital is created by a
change in persons social capital is a
change in the relations among persons a
change that renders the group more
productive and capable of doing things
it wasn't previously able to do so
social capital can arise in at least two
senses when we think about social
organization first we can think in terms
of what's flowing through the group and
across these connections is information
flowing are germs flowing our emotions
flowing is altruism flowing is this the
kind of network in which desirable
things are flowing through the system is
this the kind of group in which positive
things are primarily moving first second
social capital can arise in a second
sense which is how the groups of
individuals are organized or connected
in the first place the idea is that
social capital is a property of
collections of individuals a property
that did not exist before the people
were assembled into this network and
moreover a property that does not in
here within the individuals themselves
it's a property of the collection of
individuals again illustrating the idea
of emergence that we've been discussing
now one of the important aspects of
social capital is that it is a public
good now a public good is one in which
there is no exclusivity in consumption
so everyone can benefit from it think
about the difference between this cake
and this lighthouse if you if you have a
cake there are two things you can do
with it that are relevant to what we're
discussing right now first of all you
can prevent anyone else from eating the
cake it's your cake no one else can
touch it and second if you eat the cake
there's none of it left for either you
or anyone else to use but think instead
about the good that is the light that
comes from the lighthouse you're using
that light to avoid crashing on the
shore doesn't prevent anyone else from
using the light not only that but
there's no way to consume the light
there's no way to use it all up so a
public good is one in which there's no
exclusivity and consumption and everyone
can benefit from it and public goods
typically arise by accident maybe one
group of people puts up in the
lighthouse because they're really
learn about it maybe a Port Authority or
a private entity that is concerned about
their ships not crashing but now that
they put it up everyone can benefit and
their benefits do not reduce the ability
of the intended individuals to benefit
social capital is sort of like that it's
a public good it arises by accident from
people's interactions with each other
it's not a deliberate thing that we do
we don't set out to make it and once we
create it though everyone can benefit
from it social scientists have developed
a number of overarching approaches to
understanding human behaviors and human
society one classic way of understanding
collective behaviors is to look at
individuals themselves for example we
can see markets or elections or riots as
the mere byproduct of individuals
decisions to buy and sell goods to vote
or to express anger and the classic
example of this approach which is known
as methodological individualism is
provided by Adam Smith's conceptions of
markets or each individual transacting
their business as if guided by an
indivisible hand gives rise to a kind of
an efficient market now another classic
way of understanding collective human
behavior dispenses with individuals and
focuses on groups groups with collective
identities that cause people within the
groups to act in concert some scholars
in this tradition like Karl Marx even
believe that groups can have their own
consciousness imbuing them with a kind
of indivisible personality that cannot
be deduced or understood from the
actions of its members others have also
focused on the primacy of group culture
for example as we saw a sociologist
Emile Durkheim argued that the
relatively constant rate of suicide
within particular religious groups in
particular places at particular times
could not be explained by the actions of
individuals and must be properly
understood as a property of the
collective as a property of the groups
how was it he wondered that people came
and went but the suicide rate in French
Protestants stayed the same this is
known as methodological holism and this
approach sees
election sees groups see society as
being distinct from the constituent
individuals and sees the society and
groups as having properties that cannot
be deduced merely from studying the
Constituent individuals now in the 20th
century many social scientists focused
on how membership of individuals within
groups denoted by particular attributes
or characteristics for instance race or
class affected or helped determine the
behavior of those individuals and maybe
gave rise to collective phenomena but
the social network approaches some of
which we've been discussing today offer
a further way of understanding human
society and in fact a way perhaps best
suited for the 21st century social
networks are about both individuals and
groups and in fact they're about how
individuals become groups by connecting
to each other interconnections between
people can give rise to phenomena that
are not present with individuals
themselves and that are not reducible to
the solitary desires and actions of the
individuals the issues of social capital
and emergence and the phenomenon of
social networks that we've been
discussing illustrate the issue of how
we can come to explain social phenomena
using alternative approaches on the one
hand we have methodological
individualism here in this perspective
explanations for social phenomena such
as social class markets power
institutions and so forth must be
formulated as or reducible to the
characteristics or actions of
individuals on the other hand we could
have methodological holism here this
perspective sees each social entity
group institution or network as having a
totality that is distinct from and that
cannot be understood by merely studying
its individual component elements so for
example we may be able to understand
markets by using an approach of
methodological individualism but if we
want to understand market panics or
bubbles we probably need an approach
that uses methodological holism and
holism in fact as you probably have
gathered is related to emergence various
social
phenomena for example culture can have
an enduring reality that transcends
individuals and Durkheim for example
argued that social facts can and must be
studied by looking at groups of
individuals not individuals themselves
social capital is complicated because
certain aspects of it arise as
byproducts of individual actions so it's
true that individuals choose their
friends but in choosing their friends
they give rise to a collection a network
that has its own properties so while the
individuals contribute in some sense to
the emergence of this phenomena they are
not a part of the phenomena the
phenomenon is distinct from the
individuals and in fact the study of
social networks illustrates something
else it's part of what I call a much
broader assembly project of modern
science for the last 400 years swept by
a reductionistic fervor and by
considerable success scientists have
progressively dissected matter into ever
smaller bits
so we've disassembled life into organs
and then cells and then molecules and
the genes and we disassembled matter
into atoms then nuclei then subatomic
particles and we've invented everything
from microscopes to super colliders to
study ever smaller bits of matter but
across many disciplines right now
scientists are trying to put the bits
back together again
whether it's macromolecules into cells
neurons into brains species into
ecosystems nutrients into foods or
people into networks scientists are
turning their attention into how and why
the parts fit together to make the whole
and how interconnection can give rise to
properties that aren't present within
the component parts understanding the
structure and function of social
networks and the phenomenon of emergence
within social networks is thus part of
this larger scientific movement but
sociology has always been doing this
it's always sought to put the parts back
together into make a bigger hole it's
always realized that the whole is
greater than the sum of its parts
moreover sociology has always emphasized
the extent to which we are not in fact
masters of our own destiny and in this
regard sociology has concerned itself
with another ancient philosophical
concern namely the issue of free will
because sociology is interested in the
ways in which what happens to you aren't
just a product of your own agency don't
just depend on your own choices and
actions but depend on broader structural
factors outside of your control like the
race of your parents or your birth order
or your birth weight or the talents you
happen to be born with or super
structural factors such as the networks
you belong to or which country you were
born in or the relative wealth of these
countries or the culture of these
countries or the other attributes that
surround you that you as a part of now
come to partake of and as a result
determine your destiny just as much as
your own individual choices and actions
it's the tension between structure and
agency that we opened with to what
extent to our destinies depend on our
own behavior and to what extent do they
depend on these larger factors that
we've been discussing today if you had
asked social scientists even 20 years
ago what was their fantasy of the ideal
kind of data that they could have they
would say oh my goodness we would love
it if we could have these little tiny
helicopters that were microscopic and
invisible and they flew on top of every
person and they monitored this person 24
hours a day looking at what this person
was buying what this person who this
person was interacting with where this
person was what this person was thinking
and if they could do this for millions
of people in real time that would be
amazing we would have a kind of data
that would allow us to understand
society and individual behavior in a way
we never could before but of course
that's what we have now in our everyday
use of cell phones and credit cards and
online networks and blogs and all these
administrative records we leave these
little digital breadcrumbs as we move
about our lives that can be pulled
together and studied using new
analytical and computational tools that
give us whole new insights into how and
why society operates and the
availability of all these new kinds of
data heralds the onset of a new kind of
computational social science the
availability of data of this kind is
only in
and will continue to increase and these
data properly analyzed and subject to
ethical rules can allow us to understand
and address all kinds of important
social problems from violence to poverty
to epidemics to political extremism many
people think that the Internet is
changing something fundamental about
human interaction it is changing a few
things but the way I would describe it
is that it's the same but different if
you could ask your great-grandmother how
many friends she had when she was a 10
year old girl she would probably say to
you I had one or two best friends and
there were four or five of us girls that
were very close and if you asked my
daughter
Lenna the same question she would give
you the same answer now how can this be
how can Lenna have the same number of
friends as my great-grandmother in the
interval of time we've had the invention
of the telephone
we've had the invention of
walkie-talkies in the radio we've had
invention of of the internet we have all
these technologies yet the fundamental
reality of our social interactions
hasn't changed and the reason for this
is that what determines our social
interactions is our minds and our minds
have not changed in the last hundred
years the capacity of human beings to
desire interactions with others and the
capacity of human beings to influence
and want to be influenced by others
hasn't changed if you're interested in
understanding why people do what they do
why they have the tastes and desires
that they have or if you're interested
in understanding and sometimes why
people behave irrationally and why so
many problems seem to arise in our
society like violence and political
extremism and and poor health for
example that seem to be so against an
individual's own desires or even an
individual's own interests you need to
understand the extent to which larger
collectivities larger structures give
rise to these processes that transcend
individual desire that transcend
individual a benefit if you want to
understand all of this then you need to
understand sociology thank you
[Music]